foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and
until we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones and
House of the Dragon update video alright
my friends in this video we will be
looking at some of the new leaks
regarding House of the dragon's first
season now if these sources are accurate
it looks like the names of all the
episodes have surfaced online as well as
the length of each of the episodes as
well the first thing I want to do is
show you how long each of the episodes
will be in the first season now these
numbers are actually official because
they are from HBO's own website if you
look right here you can see just how
long the episodes will be episode 1 of
House of the Dragon will be one hour in
six minutes the second episode is 54
minutes now the third episode is coming
in at 58 minutes episode 4 is a little
over an hour at one hour and three
minutes it looks like episode 5 is
exactly one hour long episode 6 is over
an hour as well at one hour and eight
minutes episode 7 is 58 minutes and
episode 8 is 1 hour and seven minutes
long the ninth episode is exactly one
hour long and the final episode of House
of the dragon's first season is one hour
in three minutes as you can see half of
the season has episodes that run over an
hour long which is exactly what I was
hoping for now what's really interesting
is the fact that this first season of
House of the Dragon is actually longer
than every season of Game of Thrones as
a matter of fact the longest Game of
Thrones season was only 567 minutes long
whereas the first season of House of the
Dragon is 618 minutes making it the
longest season in Game of Thrones
history I must say this is one hell of a
way to start off a show this will be
absolutely necessary because House of
the dragon's first season will cover the
span of several decades at the beginning
of the Season we will see viserys
Targaryen win the great Council of 101
AC then near the end of the first season
we will see King viserys Targaryen die
in the year of 129 AC now we know the
first season of House of the Dragon will
have enough time to go over several
decades of story all right so now that
you know how long each episode will be I
want to show you the names of each of
these episodes as well as of right now I
do not know if all of these names are
official I believe a few of them are but
I can't say if all of them are accurate
now according to an unknown source the
first episode of House of the Dragon is
named Heirs of the Dragon this first
episode will introduce us to all of the
main characters with a large focus on
members of House Targaryen the second
episode is named the Rogue Prince which
is obviously a reference to Daemon
Targaryen episode 3 is named the second
of his name which might focus on viserys
and Allison's son aegon Targaryen he
will be the one who snatches the Iron
Throne right out from under his
half-sister rhaenyra Targaryen now
episode 4 is named the king of the
narrow sea it sounds like this episode
will focus on Daemon and Laura Corliss
valerion's War for the stepstones this
is when Daemon leaves King's Landing so
he can start a kingdom of his own he
does so by winning several battles on
the stepstones therefore naming himself
the king of the narrow Sea episode 5 is
named We light the way these are the
house words of house Hightower I'm
assuming this episode must focus on
Serato Hightower who is Hand of the king
and his daughter Alison Hightower who is
married to King viserys Targaryen now
episode 6 is named The Princess and the
queen this episode will focus on Alison
and rhaenyra's relationship as we've
seen in the trailers they will start out
as best friends but they will eventually
become enemies as they fight over the
Iron Throne as you can see episode 7 is
named driftmark this is the seat of
House of valerion an island not too far
from Dragonstone it looks like episode 6
and episode 7 will have a lot of focus
on this house as well because the next
episode is also called the lord of the
tides that's another reference to Laura
Corliss valerion the sea snake episode 9
is named the green Council this will
focus on Ellison Serato and their allies
in King's Landing and last but certainly
not least the final episode of House of
the dragon's first season is named The
Black Queen this episode will largely
focus on rhaenyra Targaryen and her
black Council on Dragonstone now
although I do not know if all of these
episode names are accurate I must say
they do make a lot of sense if you are
familiar with fire and blood then you
know this does sound like the order in
which these events should unfold I know
some of you don't like it when I reveal
everything that will happen which is why
I'm being kind of vague about what all
of these names actually mean I wanted to
make sure I gave you enough of a
description so you can know what the
focus of these episodes will be now if
you do want to know exactly what will
happen in those episodes just watch one
of my other videos that is down below
that video goes over everything that
will happen from the start to the finish
of this first season let me know what
all of your thoughts are about this new
information what do you think about
House of the dragon's first season being
longer than Every Game of Thrones season
also let me know what you think about
the names of each episode do any of you
think these names actually mean
something else as always I want to thank
all of you for watching the video I hope
all of you will subscribe so you can be
the first to know whenever I upload a
new video I will let you know if I find
out any more information about House of
the Dragon Game of Thrones or anything
involving A Song of Ice and Fire for
that matter have a great day everyone I
will see you again very soon bye
[Music]
thank you
foreign